[Music]
as part of our ongoing series school
matters we caught up with three teachers
who have won
the grammy music educator award in
recent years this is a very big deal the
recording academy every single year
recognizes the hard work
passion and dedication of music teachers
all across the country gail
this year's winner is mickey smith jr
he's a band director at
maplewood middle school in sulfur
louisiana
jeffrey redding won last year now he's
starting his first semester as a college
professor
at the university of central florida you
go jeffrey and melissa
salguero is a 2018 winner she's a music
teacher
at public school 48 ps48 that's here in
the bronx new york they told us
about their hopes and their concerns for
this school year now we should note that
some of the footage that you'll see
was shot before the pandemic so it's
okay
i can't hear you
music is one of the things that touches
everybody
[Music]
everybody has a favorite song that when
they hear they automatically get
put into another time and place
talking to my students and asking them
for feedback
i get so emotional talking about them
because they tell me how important music
is
ready nice
you know my biggest concern for my
students is the
the lack of normalcy every kid
wants to know that they have a safe
place they can come to
and what this new normal has done it's
it's just kind of pulled the rug from up
under all
[Music]
one of the things that i worry about is
is it going to be safe for
not only myself but also the students
so if if we can provide them that sense
of normalcy
that ability to cope that music brings i
think that goes a long way in the
healing process
i'm going to be in contact with over 600
students a week
you got to push more air in the
instrument i want to make sure
that i'm not passing on a virus
unintentionally
at the end of the day you still have to
connect with someone
[Music]
i'm going to find a way to inspire you
through
the mess now i'm going to teach you love
passion purpose
and tension we'll be zoomed we'll be
face to face
whatever we need to be i mean we won't
be that you say it
you know for the first time ever we're
all first-year teachers
i think anybody you talk to whether they
have one year of experience or
or 42 years no one's ever had to teach
like this before
but i don't think that changes the
passion and the heart people have i'm
thinking back
when i was you know was in the classroom
have you ever seen
an instrument with a caribou and i would
bring in a drill
and have the carrot there i can still do
those
things on zoom but it's really important
that
teachers are still trying to find those
lessons that
really connect with their students
make sure when you're practicing at home
you now engagement is paramount and if
you don't have engagement then they can
literally click the button and tune off
or maybe they don't even come at all
so i think that as educators my
challenge right now is
how do i make it appealing to them the
more water you put the lower the note
i'm making tick tock videos i'm making
all these sorts of social media posts to
keep them engaged over the summer time
we put together a zoom concert
my students got together we got together
on zoom we recorded our song and we did
a whole concert on zoom
i did this shakespeare production and
they should have any allegiance in them
where we recorded the kids singing
[Music]
we did like a virtual choir thing and i
feel like
those kids talk not of even though they
weren't in the same room together
even though they uh never sang a note
at the same time it's brought us closer
even though we're further away
my mother raised four boys by herself
and when she didn't have she found a way
to get and then when we had little she
found a way to make it
much what does culver teach us take what
little we have
and make it much
our sounds don't all have to be the same
but they all can work
together so when i teach my students i
don't see
students i see a symphony just know that
we're all in this together
we're all trying to figure this out
bravo but at the end of the day
teach serve whatever you do just give
just be the best version of yourself
and it will be enough
well wow such a sweet and important
story there wow
you know my little daughter rising third
grader missed music camp this summer and
that reminds me how important those
camps are and music teachers are and
also gail i know you noticed this as
well how sweet kids voices are
elementary school kids that always takes
my heart and just grabs it just a little
bit when i hear a little child's voice
but listen
mickey jeffrey melissa you see why they
all won the awards all of them
take what little you have and make it
much we're all start trying to figure
out what the new
normal i like what mickey smith jr said
he said we're all first-year teachers
everybody's learning all over again but
and i admire so much what they're doing
but boy it's hard to look at those
classes the way they were because i
i have such a nostalgia for that now you
could just see from the beginning of the
piece to how it ended how it started one
way and then ended another
where pre-code it and then clearly were
in covid nicely done